Welcome back to State of the Union
I'm Caitlin Collins.
It's a familiar biography.
A multimillionaire businessman
running for president promising
to shake up Washington.
His name is not for President Trump.
It's for Vivek Ramaswamy.
He is 37.
He's using his biotech fortune
to make early inroads
with Republican voters and the c
himself. Swami joins me now.
Thank you so much for being here
You're touting your outsider
status as equality,
but I don't know of any presiden
in recent history
we've had that did
not either
hold office
or was not a national figure
like Trump was.
So why do you think you can win
So, look, I'm running distinctiv
my vision for this country.
I'm not running on my biography
or my business credentials.
I'm running on a vision for this
that I've articulated
over the last several years.
And a lot of the conservative ba
actually is familiar
with me
through the three books
I've written, two of which are p
travel, the Country and otherwis
But my view is we're in the midd
of this national identity crisis
where if you ask most people
my age,
really any age,
what does it mean
to be an American today?
You get a blank stare in respons
And I think that is the vacuum
at the heart of our national sou
And I think that
the opportunity for the GOP
now is not just to complain
about wokeness or gender ideolog
or climate ideology,
but actually to go upstream
and fill that black hole with a
of American national identity
that runs
so deep
that it dilutes
these agendas to irrelevance
and actually unifies us as a cou
And I'm running
because I believe genuinely
that I'm the candidate best posi
to actually deliver
national unity
by reawakening
that shared American identity.
I want to ask you
more about that platform,
but you are self-funding your ca
at least for right now.
How much are you prepared to spe
So there's
there's really no limit
we've put on in terms
of what
I'm going to spend on this campa
I've been fortunate
to live
the full arc of the American dre
And if there's one thing
I care about advancing
it is about reviving that missin
national identity in our country
where we've celebrated our diver
for so long that we forgot the w
we're really just the same.
That is what I care about
more than anything. Else.
That being said,
I think a lot of businessmen
or, you know, history would teac
self-funders,
make the mistake of thinking
that they can just use their own
as a substitute
for gaining the support of voter
To the contrary,
this campaign's actually
going to be lifted up by bottom
grassroots donations.
We're already off
to a great start in the first fe
on that front as well.
So it'll be a combination
of those things.
But what it did
liberate me from as many Republi
What they do
is they ring
the tin can carry a hat in hand
and ask for donors for permissio
I was allowed to skip that step
because of,
you know, not only my accomplish
but the fact that I don't
want to be beholden
to a Republican donor class.
That's the normal gatekeeper
in this process.
One of the things I'm
calling out
on that front,
one of the things, you know,
you've been dubbed the CEO of An
You have written several of thes
You you've been very vocal
of your criticism of what you sa
is woke ism, woke religion.
Can you just define how you you
how do you define woke
Yeah, I'm going to
define it in neutral terms,
not in critical terms.
Being woke refers
to becoming alert
to invisible societal injustices
generally based on genetically
inherited characteristics like r
and sexual orientation,
and then being called upon
to act on those injustices using
potential legally means are nece
including the market to do it.
That's a neutral definition
that even most proponents of WOK
ism in the United States
would agree with.
Now, my criticism of this is
I think that it's inherently div
to tell us
that we're nothing
more than the characteristics
we inherit on the day we're born
that divides us on the basis of
and sex and sexual orientation.
And then when
that merges with capitalism,
which is what I've actually been
the biggest critic of,
what it does
is we lose the sanctuary,
the apolitical sanctuary in our
that otherwise brings us togethe
Whether we're black or white,
even whether we're Democrat
or Republican.
That's
one of the underappreciated reas
why capitalism has to stay apoli
And I'm proud to say
I've been the leader
on leading that fight
over the course
of the last couple of years
and with some progress,
because I think we're turning th
where companies are realizing
that they're not
doing good for themselves
or even doing good for society.
By engaging in these fraught pol
and social questions.
And I think we're beginning
to see that change of the tide.
I know
you have a lot of positions
on the companies aspect.
I want to get to that.
But when it comes to this,
is this your platform
would you argue
because it
when people talk about inflation
and what they're paying
at the grocery store,
do you really think
that is the message that
appeals to voters right now?
Well, I've been
that's that's the message
I've been advancing
for the last three years.
But now we're taking this
to the next level
and running for the presidency.
We're actually running
to actually deliver unity to the
It's much bigger than that.
One of the core
aspects of my platform
is actually unleashing
the American economy itself.
There's this false debate
even within the GOP between spen
or between raising taxes
between Democrats and Republican
I think we have forgotten
the biggest ingredient
to actually deliver us from our
That is GDP growth itself.
GDP growth was over 4% in this c
until the early seventies.
It's been less than two
and a half percent ever since.
I think we need to unleash
the American animal
inside the heart of the American
And so that's why
I'm taking aim
at certain opponents
or certain anti-growth measures.
I think we find a lot of that
in the climate change policies
in this country.
That's why
I've been as focused as I have
on actually unleashing
not only American energy,
but the American economy overall
But to answer your question, no,
this is about something bigger.
This is about
reviving a missing national iden
And that's the missing ingredien
to both unleashing our economy
as well as
and this is a core part of my ca
taking on the actual
foreign policy challenges
that we face on the global stage
Number one is communist China.
And I'm leading the way in this
in calling for a declaration
of independence from China,
because the key difference today
unlike the USSR in the last cent
we never depended on the Soviet
for the shoes on our feet
or the phones in our pockets.
That is the case today.
I think it's the number one
external threat we face.
And so I'm actually delivering
a vision of national identity
that hopefully allows us
to make the short run
sacrifices will need to
on the global stage
to actually win as a country
for the long run.
China is a major issue.
We'll get to that in a moment.
But do you consider yourself
a conservative How would you def
I do consider myself a conservat
but I don't believe that
the defining political debate in
this country is between Republic
and Democrats.
I think it is
between those
who are fundamentally pro-Americ
whether you believe in the ideal
that set this nation into motion
from free speech and open
debate to meritocracy
to self-governance over the aris
Do you believe in those ideals
or are you anti-American
Do you actually wish to apologiz
for a nation
whose existence
is pinned to those ideals?
And if you divide it up that way
I think it's actually an 80 20 s
in this country.
It's not just 50 50
And I think that sets up
for a potential landslide
election in 20, 24.
Frankly, part of my motivation
to run is to deliver that
because I think that's
the single most unifying thing
we could get out of this country
just like a 1980
or 1984 style
Reagan style victory as well.
So that's
the message
said about limited government.
What you were just talking there
about corporations being a polit
Do you agree with what Florida G
Ron DeSantis did with Disney
after they spoke out about his
education bill?
I would have handled that situat
a little bit differently
and I think we need
to be actually precise
about what the real drivers
are of corporate localism.
One of the underappreciated real
is that Disney's largest
shareholders are BlackRock
State Street and Vanguard.
Indeed, the three institutions
that promote ESG, environmental
and social agendas
in corporate America's boardroom
that are the largest shareholder
of most public American companie
And what they do
is they set a cultural tone
that causes these companies
to behave in politicized ways
from their boardrooms on down.
That's a problem
that needs to be fixed
through the market.
And I don't really believe
in governments,
whether it's on the left or on t
You see this on the left
to using the bully pulpit
as a way to drive corporate chan
I think the white right way to d
corporate change
is actually to do it
through the root cause itself.
And in this case,
a lot of that's top down,
driven by the ESG movement
in capital markets
and in corporate America's board